il est le grand patron d'une entreprise
qui fait beaucoup parler d'elle au
québec au canada depuis des mois et des
mois on a assisté collectivement au
démantèlement d'une partie importante de
ce qu'était bombardier avec nous le
grand patron de bombardier alain
bellemare monsieur bellemare bonsoir
monsieur bellemare j'entendais le
premier ministre aujourd'hui me suis
fait des bulles loach russie d'hier
passez une bonne transaction pis faut
voir le bon côté des choses quand même
quand vous êtes arrivé il ya cinq ans
jour pour jour je bombardier jour pour
jour ou presque
vous pensiez pas présider au
démantèlement de l'entreprise
on sait maintenant de passe l'édifice
courrier était vraiment con alentours de
la cseries à l'époque on pourrait
évidemment réaliser que le défi des plus
grandes sont à venir charge de dette
important qui était grande idée le temps
avec les développements pis la mise en
service puis le rhum peuple la mise en
cadence de la cseries du globo 7500 mais
qu'est ce qui est arrivé
mauvaise gestion ou on a vu trop grand
ou les deux je pense qu'il ya tellement
importante le premier si la suisse est
restée
c'était un projet audacieux c'est un
avion spectaculaire qui va avoir un
grand grand succès où on veut protéger
les emplois là pour des années à venir
mais ce prix est un programme qui nous a
coûté 7 milliards de dollars camille une
très lourde charge sur notre endettement
donc ça c'est la première raison la
deuxième raison c'est on l'avait dit
programme des programmes vieillissants
avait dans nous avions commerciaux le
q400 le cnj les programmes qui étaient
vraiment en bout en bout de piste où on
devait réinvestir ces programmes le
perdait de l'argent alors il y avait il
n'y avait pas de deux mosquées ça pour
construire un vaisseau mail le fic quand
vous êtes arrivé à 5,1 me bellemare vous
le saviez qu'il y avait une dette énorme
que il salem manger des milliards que ce
programme les cseries est ce que vous
auriez pas pu faire les choses autrement
non mais ce qu'on ne sait pas si ce qui
est devant on est capable de regarder en
arrière mais de plaisir qu'on a ri on
connaît pas bien l'entreprise c'est
assez difficile donc dans la première
année on
en place un plan de redressement
ministre l'horizon de cinq ans ce qu'on
a
j'ai réalisé les défis contre les défis
opérationnels qu'on avait à compléter
nos deux gros programmes d'aviation dont
le cseries et le globo 1 500 et par le
sud on ne signale attaque et on a
travaillé à mettre en service ces deux
appareils qui sont extraordinaires
aujourd'hui mais la charge de dette a
continué à croître et ce qu'on a
toujours dit ce qu'est en 2020 on devait
adresser cette charge de dette là donc
on s'est engagé dans une aventure
puis on se savait qu'on allait devoir se
départir du bébé un jour et le donner à
quelqu'un comme airbus dont les cseries
au fil des mois d'enquêté remis à hervé
assez rapidement ouf j'ai réalisé qu'on
n'y avait pas les moyens financiers de
faire vis ce programme le seul alors
quand on dit qu'on est nuls le programme
c'est un grand mot parce que la réalité
c'est que bombardier seul ne pouvait pas
faire fonctionner ce prix là je vous
arrête à quelle maman est arrivée à la
conclusion que bombardier ne pouvait pas
se faire dans les stalles si rapidement
assez rapidement en 2015 parce que on a
eu des approches avec airbus en 2015 et
en 2016 pour essayer d emmener comme
partenaire c'est le pot était sale après
on n'a pas eu de succès quand vous avez
levé la main vous avez demandé aux
québécois au gouvernement du québec de
monsieur couillard à l'époque de données
1,3 milliards canadiens pour les cseries
est ce que vous saviez à ce moment là
que c'était même risqué cet
investissement mais c'est sûr que quand
on développe des programmes de cette
taille là c'est des programmes qui sont
risqués 15 contre pau d'histoire mais la
réalité ce qu'ils avaient encore une
façon de sauver le programme et de le
faire fonctionner avec un partenaire et
l'investissement du gouvernement du
québec à l'époque c'était de créer un
pont vers un partenariat avec un grand
joueur
ok mais le grand joueur et est pas
encore là là non on le cherchait le
grand joueur qui mêle d'un point de vue
du contribuable québécois sur balma
est-ce que ça 1,3 milliard là était une
mauvaise affaire
ce qu'on peut le dire clairement
aujourd'hui non c'est pas une mauvaise
affaire pour nous parce qu'elle sert du
600 millions l'ont écrit
trois mille trois cents jeunes donc
trois mille trois cents familles qui à
chaque jour sont nourries parce que on à
eelv on on ne travaille pour eux c'est
poirier il ya donc il ya un impact
économique direct
la pression n'est pas un impact
économique indirect sur le réseau qui
est qui entoure ce programme là et en
plus vous permet elle de la prison qui
était prise olive par le grand match le
gouvernement du québec c'est une prison
qui au jour aux présentement à la valeur
de l'entreprise qui était réagis tu es
mais quand gouvernement va sortir en
2026 les chansons que le programme va
avoir une plus grande valeur donc on
peut retrouver même cet investissement
alors qu'est ce qui serait arrivé si le
grenade québec n'avait pas investi 1,3
milliard je pense que j'avais des
chances qu'on ferme le programme donc
plus d'emplois terminé à prévoir on est
on est on est on le tourne avait des
chances on avait des chances ou c'était
sûr que ça ferme et auch aussi du jeu je
peux pas vous dire que ça fermé mais ça
faisait partie des options de ferme il
pourra g parce qu'on n'avait plus les
moyens de continuer sur le programme
bon ceci laventure des avions puis mal
aux pieds on va voir si airbus va garder
les emplois mirabel ou pas pendant très
longtemps on le souhaite
non mais ils commettent menu un
engagement aussi très important de
comprendre qu'on a mis en place la
coentreprise avec airbus
ils se sont engagés à garder le siège
social de ce créneau des violents de 100
à 105 en place à mirabel pour 25 ans les
trains loyers les avions on renonce à ce
rêve là quand même de piloter dans tous
les sens du mot ce nouvel appareil
commercial d'avoir les deux mains sur le
volant d'être propriétaire ne l'est plus
les trains c'est la même chose on au
pourquoi vous avez été obligé de
bazarder haut à ce point toute
l'entreprise
les la dette était tellement grande
qu'on lui a fallu qu'on vend toute la
maison ouais on est en avait plus la
capacité financière de supporter cette
charge de dette là on a neuf points 3
milliards de dollars de dettes
on a vu où son instrument
de la caisse de dépôt dans le train qui
aujourd'hui ont le vus vous 2.3
milliards de dollars us lorsque l'on
investit 1.5 milliard de dollars donc
pour nous le dette totale était de plus
de 12 milliards de dollars if on devait
on avait deux bus nous les avions
d'affaires
électron et on devait prendre une
décision à savoir comment on pouvait
accélérer le remboursement de la dette
qu'est ce qui reste là il reste les
avions d'affaires c'est tout mais c'est
beaucoup c'est je vous remercie de me
poser la question les gens et je voulais
mais qu'est ce qu'il reste de ce joyau
c'est les avions d'affaires
oui mais les avions d'affaires le sait
des revenus de 6 milliards de dollars
canadiens 7 milliards de dollars us
ces dix huit mille personnes ces dix
mille personnes
ici au québec c'est treize mille
personnes au canada
on y encore le corps de la grappe
aéronautique au québec puis au canada
on y le plus grand joueur mondial dans
les avions d'affaires
on est deux au top des avions d'affaires
et on a des produits qui sont
exceptionnelles puis on vient de sortir
d'un cycle d'investissements majeurs
alors ses poiriers c'est une super belle
entreprise il ya quelqu'un qui a comparé
bombardier au canadien de montréal dans
le domaine de la business de l'industrie
quand la répression que non seulement
fait pas les séries mais l'équipe a été
vendu 600 l'impression qu'on ne
comprenait que le bombardier qu'on a
connu qu on a rêvé n'existe plus quand
mais je pense que bombardier maintenant
on tourne la page on complet aujourd'hui
on complète le plan de redressement ce
qui était vraiment une bonne nouvelle en
soi et on ouvre un nouveau chapitre qui
va être forcé sur une entreprise qui
soleil les avions d'affaires
créatrice de richesses et qu'on est
capable de continuer à faire croire
parce que on ne
on a une situation financière qui est
adressé bon c'est plus simple quand la
cseries était vraiment dans une période
extrêmement difficile quand vous avez
levé la main
et que les contribuables ont accepté
d'aider bombardier ce qui a beaucoup
choqué les gens c'est les salaires des
hauts dirigeants le vôtre en commençant
pour reprendre l'analogie de hockey vous
êtes payés comme un marqueur de 50 buts
à 12 13 14 millions par année puis 2
puis 5 1 vais pas ce cas aurait tendance
à long terme du grand public
est-ce que ça il n'y aurait pas dû avoir
une prudence une morale même pour que le
conseil d'administration et vous vous
vous disiez et les boys ou peux-tu
amputant lé c'est un peu pour les autres
secteurs
je pense qu'il ya deux trois points
importants lada un bon salaire gel de
cette fois c'est décidé par le conseil
d'administration s'est basé sur des
comparables dans l'industrie est la
deuxième chose c'est mon salaire est
basé sur la performance de l'entreprise
donc lorsque l'entreprise performe pas
non plus genre gens bénéficient pas et
troisièmement je pense que j'ai entré
dans une situation où il y avait un
redressement qui était vraiment vraiment
profond qui était vraiment demande en
exigeant et on ne bâtit une équipe
spectaculaire pour travailler avec moi
pour redresser l'entreprise puis
aujourd'hui je suis vraiment fier de
dire qu'on a mis bombardier je comprends
mieux aujourd'hui avec le recul je parle
pas que de votre salaire mais aussi
amener on a vendu 30 millions d'actions
l'aller les dirigeants est ce qu'il y
aurait pas dû avoir une prudence
institutionnels morale pour dire on y va
mollo s'il vous plaît non mais je pense
que c'était fait mais je peux passer
d'entrevue par le marché mais un conseil
d'administration ce minutes du final
c'est la première minute là dessus et ça
préoccupe les gens qu'ils ont donnée
mais je pense que c'est important de
réaliser que les salaires des dirigeants
ces contrôles est dirigée par un conseil
d'administration et un comité de
ressources humaines qui s'occupe de
s'assurer que les salaires sont
compétitives pour retenir attirer et
retenir les talents la famille beaudoin
bombardier at-elle une responsabilité
dans ce qui arrive actuellement mais je
pense qu'elle est une famille qui ont le
québec accord et qu'ils veulent qu'elle
l'entreprise continue à croître et à
grandir ici au québec
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on tourne une
page cependant on ouvre un nouveau
chapitre
c'est une compagnie c'est une famille
qui ont pris des idées des projets des
cabinets rêve grand avec des projets
audacieux celui de la cseries
ça ne crée quelque chose d
extraordinaire
malheureusement on n'avait pas les reins
assez solides pour la mener à terme
mais le programme drame quand même c'est
malheureux je pense souvent chez moi je
moi je veux pas ça comme un drame parce
qu'il ya propriétaires différents
maintenant qui est herbeuse qui va
continuer à faire coincer de ce
programme là le carnet de commandes est
maintenant 700 avions il ya du travail
pour les prochaines années et sous le
leadership d'airbus qui sont vraiment
dans ce créneau là ils vont être
capables d'en faire un grand succès
restez-vous dans l'entreprise c'est ce
que vous restez un boutin ou même entre
eux à venir moi mon présentement mon
focus et des comptes de compléter mon
plan de redressement puis de m'assurer
qu'elle a entreprises ont continué à
croître
combien de temps vous restez combien
temps mais j'ai pas de juger j'ai pas de
géant dans la vente alstom la française
est-ce qu'on va apprendre qu'il ya eu
des bonus ou si extraordinairement élevé
pour la haute direction
encore une fois pour moi je décide pas
de sens et pour moi et je pense qu'il
faut que les gens comprennent c'est pas
moi qui décide de mon salarié un conseil
d'administration qui regardent ce à la
lumière des résultats et de la
performance de l'équipe de m de
management et le décide alors y
décèleront pour moi jure je vais je
prends ce qu'on me donne très bien les
bellemare merci d'être venu sur le
plateau on verra pour les emplois je
pense qu'en dernier lieu c'est à eux
qu'on veut penser aussi que ce soit
mirabel à la pocatière un peu partout
que ça ça se poursuive pour le meilleur
mais je pense que c'est mon père m'a t
elle
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on à protéger
tous ces emplois là et la venue d'
alstom peut être vue de la même façon
que l'arrivée d'airbus airbus consolider
la grappe aéronautique au québec et au
canada
airbus arrive c'est une compagnie très
importante au niveau du transport sur
rail vous êtes capable de créer des
opportunités pour st bruno pour la
pocatière pour nos opérations ici puis
utiliser les connaissances et le savoir
qu'on a ici au québec soit on l'a merci
beaucoup monsieur bah merci à vous merci
merci merci roi